hi I'm Alex Berenson I'm a former
reporter for the New York Times and the
author of the book tell your children
the truth about marijuana mental illness
and violence
I've spoken to Hillsdale audiences about
that in the past I'm here today to talk
to you about the corona virus our
modeling of it and what the failure of
the most important models we've used to
predict the course of the virus mean and
what they should tell us about lock
downs and our strategy going forward so
let's talk a little bit about models and
what they are and why they're important
at the you know at the most basic level
the corona virus is a is a novel illness
it's a novel virus there are other kinds
of corona viruses but when this one
emerged in China in January to 2020 we
didn't have very much idea about what it
was how dangerous it might be medically
and you know at a cellular level how it
affected people but though the medical
and biological issues are are sort of
outside of my domain I'm more interested
in the the submerged level the
population level effects that we're
trying to to figure out you know I'm not
a molecular biologist I wouldn't pretend
to know how the corona virus infects a
cell on the you know on the most basic
cellular level but I can tell you
whether or not the predictions that are
made about the transmissibility of the
virus and the the ultimate population
effects of the virus are what we're
seeing in reality that's that doesn't
require a PhD in molecular biology just
requires the ability to compare
different sets of numbers and track them
in real time which is really what I've
been doing for the last month or so so
models matter why do they matter they
matter because people are using them you
know in in hospital systems at state
levels at national levels at
international levels to figure out how
many people might become sick from the
corona virus how many people might need
ventilators or ICU beds from the corona
virus how many people might die from the
corona virus obviously if 10 percent of
the population is going to die you know
we need to take really drastic steps if
1 in 1,000 people is going
perhaps the coronaviruses more like the
flu and we can treat it more like the
flu so we need to know where the
epidemic is going to go in the days and
weeks before it gets there or that's
certainly what we're hoping to do and
the models help us get there and the
science of Epidemiology and infectious
disease has been around a long time it's
been it's been really developing for
more than a century and a half so
there's a you know there's a lot and
epidemics come and go over time so
there's a lot of history here there's a
lot to draw on here so when people are
talking about models what are they
talking about they're talking about
trying to predict the course of the
epidemic in the coming weeks months you
know ideally years although as you go
further and further out it becomes
harder and harder to predict how do you
do that well you need some basic facts
about the virus you need to know how
transmissible it is in other words if I
get sick how many people on average am I
going to sick you know if if I'm only
gonna sick in one person the virus the
the epidemic is gonna spread slowly if
I'm gonna sick in 20 people as actually
can be the case in the case of something
like measles the epidemic is gonna
spread very rapidly we also want to know
how quickly that transmission cycle
takes place how many days am I likely to
be infectious how many days am i likely
to be infectious before I know I'm
infectious before I'm showing symptoms
that's a crucial variable just to give
you an example of how big the
uncertainties can be here if the are the
transmissibility is - meaning one person
infects two other people and the cycle
is six days over the course of a month
one infection might become 30 infections
which you know that's that's obviously a
big change but if the R is three one
person is sickening three people or a
little bit more than three yeah three
point one to be precise and and the
transmission cycle is four days over
that same month one person can sicken or
it's not that one person will sick in
10,000 people but one infection will
become 10,000 infection
so in our of three a transmission cycle
of four one becomes 10,000 an R of two
transmission cycles six days and R
becomes a bit more than 30 over the
course of month these are huge
differences and on four end so that's
one thing you need to know how fast the
virus spreads we need to know where it
goes
we'd like to really know what what
vectors are most likely to spread it in
other words our children spreading this
to adults or adults spreading this to
children does this spread if we're
outside just in talking to people or
does it require pretty close contact you
know is in-home transmission the main
method of transmission is transmission
on public transportation the main method
these are these are more subtle
questions but they're they're also
crucially important in terms of Devon
devising a societal response and we want
to know can they are change how quickly
you know what might drive our up or
lower it does a there's a hard lock down
lower it very fast as modern social
distancing lower very fast those are
those are you know again those are sort
of second level questions before you can
even get to those you need to know the
basics about transmissibility and the
reproductive cycle of the virus and
again some of that depends on the
biological characteristics of the virus
which are you know which scientists in
labs all over the world are trying to
figure out but some of those depend on
for lack of a better where the
sociological characteristics of what
we're doing are we pushing people into
emergency rooms are there is there a
Mardi Gras event where you know tens or
hundreds of thousands of people are
getting together for a parade all of
those things are not actually so much
about the virus as about us and so they
can change very rapidly more rapidly
actually than the than the fundamental
characteristics of the virus so that so
so transmissibility is one key number
and then the other key number is the
fatality rate
well the hospitalization rate but
ultimately the fatality rate of the
virus how many people who get this are
going to get sick and how many of those
people are going to die and obviously
again a virus that kills and you know
something like Ebola might kill half the
people and in fact something like HIV
before there were anti retrovirals would
kill 100% of the people that infected
you know with a you know with the with a
very unusual exception or to everybody
who got HIV ultimately died of of AIDS
so some viruses are extremely Lethal
other viruses like the flu much less the
common cold are much less lethal and so
that and the spectrum really can be
anywhere from zero to a hundred percent
and early on as you're as you're
figuring out is you're trying to figure
out these models you may not have great
information about the fatality rate
you're making some guesses and that was
really very true in this case because a
lot of the data was coming out of China
and I would say you know people are
pretty suspicious even now of some of
the data that that the Chinese
government has reported you know it's
not entirely clear that they were
counting cases accurately they kept
changing the definitions of cases you
know there are people who don't believe
the fatality numbers that they reported
the death numbers that they reported you
know I don't really I try not to engage
in conspiracy theory but you know China
is in a an authoritarian state and I do
think there are there are legitimate
questions about the data that came out
of China in the first month so the
people who were who were who were
charting these models who are creating
these models especially in March as the
as the epidemic spread you know outside
of China to Europe and then to the
United States we're doing so with
somewhat limited information and they
had to make guesses and when you're
making these models I think there's a
natural tendency probably to want not to
err on the side of under estimating the
danger he did so if you if you if you
overestimate the danger maybe you know
maybe you cause problems with the
economy or other problems that you know
these people who are making the models
don't necessarily focus on but if you
underestimate the data people die is I
think you sort of the so the bias tends
to be to overestimate the risk here and
so again you need to we all should
remember that as these models were being
created when
didn't have great data about either the
transmissibility or the infection
fatality rate and by the way the
infection fatality rate can change too
it can change for a number of reasons it
can change if we get pharmaceutical
interventions so you know people people
have talked about antiviral drugs or you
know or zinc and Zi packs and hcq and
it's not clear by the way that any of
those interventions actually work they
need to be tested in placebo controlled
trials where they're tested against
basically nothing so we can see if
they're better or worse than nothing
because making guesses on the basis of
anecdotes is not a good idea but over
time you would expect and hope that
physicians will come up with treatments
for these you know for the corona virus
that will reduce the fatality rate
another another and there may be you
know physical interventions like
literally just having people lie on
their stomachs it's called proning them
that appears to actually help some
people not become to not need to go on
ventilators not become too oxygen
deprived and so physicians learn and
they learn quickly and but at the same
time we need to make sure that they're
not just going on anecdotes so it's so
it's a very complicated process but the
infection fatality rate can change and
and it can change the other way you know
I think there's increasing evidence and
increasing debate in the medical
community about the use of ventilators
and whether whether if you overuse
ventilators you might wind up hurting
some people because of some specific
characteristics of the way the corona
virus affects the lungs and so
ultimately if you use ventilators too
aggressively you might even wind up
killing some people who might otherwise
have survived and that's you know that
it's a very tricky balance you know I'm
not a physician my wife is a physician
and she actually treats coded patients
and and I'm very respectful of the of
the choices that physicians have to make
in some of these cases with very limited
information but the point is the
infection fatality rate can change and
so can the our okay so that's
that's what the people who are creating
the models those are the limitations
they're facing and it's a little bit
think of it a little bit like a
hurricane prediction at some point if
you have too many uncertainties the
prediction is just useless
so if if I'm predicting that a hurricane
might hit Miami on a Tuesday in August
and it might be a category three to
category five that's a pretty you know I
know and I know the date it's you know
Tuesday August 21st I'm just making that
data up but you know it might be Miami
or it might be Fort Lauderdale or might
be you know a little bit further north
that's a good enough prediction that we
can do something with that we can
evacuate South Florida we can say to
people we don't know that this is gonna
be the worst thing ever but it could be
and even if it's not it's gonna cause
some problems so let's let's get you
know let's get people in South Florida
out of of Miami
let's get them you know let's get them
to someplace it's a little bit safer if
my prediction is that there's gonna be a
hurricane sometime in August that's
gonna hit somewhere between Miami and
New York City and it might be a category
one or it might be a category three or
it might be category five that's useless
and it's especially useless if my policy
prescription as a result of that
prescription or that prediction is not
just hey we need to evacuate the whole
Atlantic seaboard but let's burn the
whole seaboard down and to some extent
that is the you know that is the choice
that we've made with these lockdown so
so at some point the prediction becomes
too nebulous to be of any use no matter
how well-intentioned it is and you know
unfortunately what is obvious when I
when I use the hurricane analogy was not
obvious last month when we were talking
about these models so the first model
that really grabbed a lot of attention
came out on March 16th and it came out
from Imperial College in London and what
it said was that two million people in
the United States and 500,000 people in
Britain would probably die from the
corona virus if no steps were taken and
that even if pretty aggressive
mitigation as the authors called it was
used the deaths would be at roughly half
that level so more than
in the u.s. a quarter million in Britain
now the people who did this were led by
a professor named Neil Ferguson who's a
British professor who's a you know a
very well respected epidemiologist I
think what was forgotten at the time
although it's become I don't say obvious
but it's become noticed since is that
professor Ferguson has a long history of
making very aggressive predictions about
death and from from epidemics he
predicted in 2005 that as many as 200
million people might die from the bird
flu that was that was around that year
he predicted in 2001 that as more than a
hundred thousand people in Britain might
die from mad cow disease and he also
predicted that it might lead to sheep
and create mad sheep disease and that
ultimately 150,000 people might die now
obviously those estimates turned out not
to be the case but nonetheless when the
Imperial College model came out it was
very it received tremendous attention in
both the US and the UK and you know the
New York Times oh she wrote a story a
front-page story on March 17th talking
about the impact that the model had had
on policymakers in the US and the UK and
and I'd been paying attention to the
coronavirus pretty aggressively since
since early or not not early since late
January since you know that the numbers
sort of came out of China and I and I
was concerned about it and I would say
that I was a little puzzled in late
February because we didn't see the
epidemics the secondary epidemics in
other china mega cities that that were
being predicted after the initial Wuhan
epidemic we didn't see Beijing get
overrun we didn't see Shanghai get
overrun you know the epidemic seemed
weirdly confined to Wuhan and or you
know in Hebei Province and these other
cities even after they began to you know
reduce their lockdowns and quarantines
they didn't show huge spikes so that
puzzled me but then of course Italy
northern
especially the hospitals faced a
terrible damage and that was you know
that was very scary and then the the you
know the paper came out on March 16th
and I think I read it that night and
what really struck me was the age
stratification in the data meaning
people over 70 and certainly people over
80 of account from the majority people
over 70 come from the vast majority of
coronavirus desk people over 80 account
for the majority my best estimate is
that worldwide more people over 100 have
died than under 30 believe it or not and
more people over 90 have died than under
50 so this is a this is an epidemic that
is really really stratified by age your
risks are much much higher if you're
older which doesn't mean it's not
serious and it doesn't mean that the
deaths of people over 80 or 90 don't
matter but it does it does suggest that
the the virus itself is not so terribly
dangerous if it isn't hurting younger
people you know it's not the Spanish flu
which you know which which which killed
a lot of children a lot of young adults
and a lot of older people so that you
know so the Spanish flu analogy probably
isn't a great analogy so so I looked at
the at the Imperial College data and
Imperial College was very explicit about
this that to get numbers down to some
reasonable level we were gonna have to
suppress the they use the term
suppression suppress Society for a very
long time
they said 18 months but if you actually
read the paper it maybe the paper makes
clear that 18 months is just essentially
a number that they're using to say it
might take 18 months to get to a vaccine
and if we you know basically until we
get to a vaccine suppression is gonna
have to continue if we don't want these
terrible deaths tools to mount a you
know a million people in the US a
quarter million in the UK and and so you
know that that scared people even you
know I think I think the top line number
got a lot of attention understandably
and people focus less on the age
stratification and you know the the big
gap in risk by age so so then what
happened was I believe was March 23rd
Neil Ferguson gave testimony to
Parliament
and he said well you know our new best
estimate is twenty thousand deaths in
Britain with it with a couple of weeks
of lockdown and and that got some
attention in the UK it didn't get any
attention in the US
wherewhere attention was becoming very
very focused on what was happening in
New York City and the death counts in
you know in the hospitalizations in New
York City and Governor Cuomo predicting
that we might need as many as 140,000
beds here in New York State hospital
beds as many as thirty to forty thousand
ventilators really terrifying stories
coming out in the New York Times about
how you know a million people might need
to be on ventilators which one Times
reporter then said meant that a million
ventilators might be needed which was an
absurd statement in under any
circumstance because a ventilator
useless without the trained you know
nurses and doctors and medical staff to
run it and so there's no circumstance
under which a million ventilators ever
made any sense but but going back to
Britain and to Professor Fergusson
professor Fergusson who by this time had
actually contacted the coronavirus
himself been infected with the corona
virus yet suddenly changed his estimate
to 20,000 and he did this again it
wasn't quiet it was it was it was before
a parliamentary hearing in the UK but it
didn't get very much attention and he
said well we think the transmissibility
has gone is higher than we thought so so
what does that mean well if the
transmissibility is higher that means a
much larger group of people have gotten
this over the course of the last couple
of months than we realized and that's a
good thing the more people who've gotten
it that means that the number of people
walking around with no symptoms at all
is higher than we think and that means
that the virus is less dangerous than we
think and now if if if 10 million people
are infected and 10,000 ultimately die
that's a 1 in 1,000 death rate that's
like the flu if if if a hundred thousand
people get it and 10,000 die that's a 10
percent death rate that's nothing like
the flu that's much much worse and so
and in that case we have to be terrified
that ultimately you know those 10
million people will get it
of those will die but what what but
Professor Fergusson was saying was we
think more people have gotten this and
therefore it just doing the math it
can't be as dangerous as we thought
although he didn't explicitly come out
and say that so I pointed this out in a
couple of tweets the next day once I
realized what he had said and and that's
really that was about a month ago that's
really when I started to become you know
a little bit of people call me a
contrarian or skeptic on this I think
I'm just trying to point to data that
you know that other that other outlets
may not be pointing to but so so
professor Ferguson then said well we
didn't really change our model five
hundred thousand two hundred fifty
thousand twenty thousand all those
numbers are in our model and that is
true they're all in there but what he
didn't say was that he fundamentally
changed the assumptions around the model
around the around the deaths around the
twenty thousand death figure whereas
before the assumptions in I'm talking
about in the paper you can see it in the
paper the assumptions are we need again
18 months of suppression to get to
twenty thousand deaths
even if we have just a few months of
mitigation of somewhat severe societal
measures but not a full lockdown we're
gonna have a quarter million deaths all
of a sudden he's saying well with just a
couple of weeks of lockdown I think
we're twenty thousand deaths and he also
said explicitly most of those people
will be will be elderly or quite sick or
in and have less than a year to live
they would have died anyway by the end
of the year I think was his phrase I I
can check that and so so you know he
said twenty thousand deaths in the UK
was the most likely estimate and again
most of those people already already old
you know already would have died quite
soon anyway and so again I pointed this
out he then responded not directly to me
but you know he was responding clearly
to the fact that I had pointed this out
and said oh well we didn't really change
anything and there were you know there
were some media outlets that effectively
accepted that narrative and nobody
seemed to go back and say well professor
Ferguson what about all these other
times when you
you know vastly overstated estimates for
death counts so that so so the Imperial
College model was the model that really
grabbed the tension in the US and the UK
and really pushed policymakers into a
lockdown into lockdown mode I mean it
certainly got the attention of the White
House and it started this you know this
sort of domino effect where first some
states on the west coast you know
lockdown and then New York said they
weren't going to and then they did and
then more and more states followed and
you know there was increasing national
pressure for the few states but you know
by I would say the end of March the the
last week of March the states that
hadn't locked down yet we're feeling you
know considerable media pressure and
some public / political pressure to lock
down and most of them ultimately did so
so the Imperial College model you know
was changed in a way that that that
again again if you read the original
paper it's clear that change that you
know that that it was changed and I I
don't I don't think that anybody who
reads with a with a fair mind could
could could dispute that but but
actually the model that has become more
important in the US and and is even
enemies and is more provably wrong and
more consequentially wrong in the last
month is the University of Washington
model okay so what is the University of
Washington model well on on March 26th
the University of Washington Institute
for Health metrics and evaluation
released a very detailed model
state-by-state and actually they've
extended it to many countries saying
this is how many beds hospital beds we
think states are going to need this is
how many ventilator states are going to
need this is how many deaths were gonna
have and so and so this became a guide
to state planning and what the March
26th model showed was that all states
practically but especially New York
State were in terrible trouble and and
so and so in New York State
I believe the
the one of the or maybe the second
iteration of the model what the
prediction was it was going to need
76,000 hospital beds and you know in in
in tens of thousands of ventilators an
attic see wasn't as bad as the state's
own projections which again were as many
as a hundred forty thousand hospital
beds and thirty thousand ventilators
thirty to forty thousand ventilators
okay and it and in many other states the
predictions were quite you know they
were extremely high ultimately I think
they you know the the April fifth
version of this predicted two hundred
and sixty thousand hospital beds needed
nationally which is a you know an
enormous number okay so where did this
come from here's what happened in New
York City a'right you need to understand
what happened to New York City from
March about March 15th to March 25th
hospitalizations increased dramatically
they increased almost tenfold so you
know in mid-march there were a hundred
people showing up with kovat related
illness in New York City hospitals are
being hospitalized by March 25th that
number was over a thousand okay and the
key metric here is hospitalizations why
because deaths are a lagging indicator
and by the way right now in the United
States because the death coding is so I
would say aggressive and loose it's not
even clear you know in some cases people
who didn't even have the corona virus
might be counted as a corona virus
related death at the same time in places
that are really badly and we know that
we're really badly impacted which
basically means in New York City it's
possible that there were some people who
died who weren't counted even though
they did die of coronavirus oh so the
death counts are complicated
hospitalizations are or a better metric
for the most part because no good doctor
is gonna hospitalized somebody you know
for coronavirus or anything else who
doesn't need to be hospitalized so
here's here's here's the crucial part of
this you become infected with corona
virus it takes several days before you
develop symptoms on average about five
days some people develop more rapidly
some people it takes longer then you get
worse over time and over a period of
days five days six days seven days
ultimately you you get sick enough that
you're in the hospital and from there
you oftentimes you progress pretty
rapidly you you know you might wind up
in the ICU or on a ventilator or you
might you know you might die or in some
cases many cases actually you don't you
know you you you feel better after a day
or two in the hospital and you're
discharged okay so but the main thing is
there's a lag there's a lag between
infection and symptoms symptoms and
hospitalization in New York City the
lockdowns I believe it was the state
Governor Cuomo announced the lockdown on
I want to say Friday March 21st and they
were to take effect on March 23rd Sunday
March 23rd what people were afraid of
and what the models essentially
predicted was that the lock downs
occurred too late okay and that in the
10-day period before the lock downs took
place there was going there had been a
massive surge in hospitalizations and
that surge was going to continue I'm
sorry a massive search and infections in
fact day after day infections increasing
and those increased infections were
going to lead to a massive wave of
hospitalizations that wasn't going to
peak on March 25th because that's too
close to the lockdown but that was going
to continue the increase increased day
after day after day until five or six or
seven thousand people a day were being
hospitalized for this you know and and
the hospitals were not gonna be able to
cope with this and that that was what
was terrifying to people that not that
the lock downs were were we're going to
work but that the lock downs weren't
going to work because they taken place
too late
that is the core assumption at that you
know even though it's not explicitly
stated it is the core assumption in the
University of Washington model certainly
for New York State but what happened
wasn't that at all what happened was
that hospitalization stayed relatively
high for several days really ten or more
days following that March 25th date but
they didn't continue to increase
exponentially and so every day the
models got a little bit more wrong
so bye bye-bye you know early April the
models were predicting or I shouldn't
say the models there's one model it's
the University of Washington model
they're predicting that that as many as
60,000 people would need
hospitalizations in New York State but
in reality the number was more like
15,000 and and a gap continued to
increase and so looking at that I sigh I
realized wow there's something very you
know there's something very seriously
wrong with this prediction because this
was released on March 26th and it's not
trying to predict three months or a year
what it is trying to predict those
things in the future or five years in
the future its predicting days in the
future and it's completely wrong it's as
if I said you know this hurricane again
to come back to this I say on August
31st this hurricane is going to hit and
it's gonna be a category 5 in Miami on
September 3rd and the hurricane comes
ashore on September 3rd but it's a
category one so so the the the
predictions were just way off and they
again they were way off because they
assumed this surge in infections had
happened that didn't seem to have
happened and we still don't quite know
why that is but but one you know one
good theory is that more people were
infected earlier than we know so again
that means that although there was a
surge in infections in New York City in
those days ultimately fewer people wound
up in the hospital than we realized so
so it was it was it was my prodding at
the University of Washington model day
after day that that again I would say
increase my public profile a little bit
and increased people's questioning about
this because those those two models the
Imperial College model and the
University of Washington model
led to the lockdown and are continuing
to leads the lockdown and one of the one
of the amazing things that happened was
the University of Washington continued
to update its model they would they
updated it they've now updated I believe
five times possibly six times
in the last you know in the last month
but but on April 5th they changed the
predict projections and they changed
them from from about 260,000 hospital
beds needed to about a hundred and forty
thousand hospital beds needed what was
bizarre was even as they changed the
model that day they didn't make it match
what the actual numbers were in New York
State that day so even the new model was
wrong at the time it was issued and once
I saw that I thought to myself this is
really bad you know this is this is not
this is not okay it's not okay that this
incredibly important
you know predictor that's driving public
policy isn't even being corrected to
what we know is actually happening in
New York State and other states at this
time now the models to be clearer have
been more accurate about death counts
now that's there's a couple reasons for
that first of all again deaths are a
lagging indicator and again and second
of all there is this issue about how
we're coding for deaths but the what we
should care about more than anything
else is hospitalizations because
Hospital both because hospitalizations
are a leading indicator and tell us how
seriously the disease is you know for
the general population and not just for
a small group of elderly people who you
know who are really at risk but also
because if you remember a month ago when
the lockdowns began the argument was we
need to do this to save our healthcare
system it is not we cannot have a
situation where every hospital is going
broke is overrun with kovat patients and
can't do anything else and we are
working our doctors and nurses and
medical staff to death we can't have
that happen that's and that's a totally
reasonable way to look at it the problem
is the models predicted a destruction of
the healthcare system that hasn't
happened at all not even in New York
City in New York City got stretched and
it probably you can argue guys stretch
close to its limits but the overflow
capacity that was brought in you know
the the
the hospital ships and the field
hospitals have never been full so even
by even New York City survived without
being overrun and elsewhere this
incredible paradox has happened and this
is something I was reporting on a lot a
couple of weeks ago I'd say at this
point it's beyond dispute where
hospitals all over the country are
emptier than they were a month or six
weeks ago and they are bleeding cash
because they have postponed elective
surgeries because people aren't coming
into their emergency rooms because in
some cases really necessary surgeries
are being postponed and so our hospital
system believe it or not is on the brink
of collapse
not from Kovac but because we reacted to
these models by shutting down a ton of
stuff that hospitals need to be able to
survive financially and hospitals in the
United States have already closed in the
last month they've laid off employees
and some have Believe It or Not closed
so we are in the midst of the worst
pandemic supposedly since the Spanish
flu and our hospitals are closing for
lack of business and once you realize
that you realize that how important it
is that these models have been wrong so
so I would just I just urge everybody
going forward to understand that you
know there's been many predictions of
doom made in the last month there's been
the just wait two weeks predict there's
in the model predictions there's been
the wait 2 week predictions there's been
the second wave which by the way is
basically meaningless because the second
wave could happen at any time it could
happen next fall or next or in the
spring of 2021 or you could happen in
two years I mean you know at what point
that we do we say okay there may
ultimately be more deaths even
significantly more deaths from this but
we can't stay you know in our homes with
no economy forever and and so so it
really is the models more than anything
else that have driven this and it's
really important to understand how far
from reality they've been and that's and
that's what I've tried to do as much as
anything else the last month anyway I
thank you very much oh the one other
point I would make is about testing so
yeah that one thing that people have
said is we need we need many many more
tests well the truth is we don't
necessarily need many many more tests to
know if people are infected as long as
they're not symptomatic or needing
hospitalization you don't necessarily
care if you have the flu or not if
you're you know if you feel lousy for a
couple of days but you you know you know
it's the flu and you know it's gonna
pass you probably just stay home for
those couple of days
the corona virus tests are necessary if
corona virus is going to you know kill a
lot of the door you know or seriously
injure a lot of the people who get it
and we have good interventions for them
what is more important than knowing how
many people are infected now what is
much more important is knowing how many
people have been infected and recovered
and for that it you need a different
kind of test which is called an antibody
test which is a very simple test that
just shows whether your body has
produced an immune response to the virus
and these are they're your they're
relatively cheap they're relatively
quick to do and they've been conducted
now in a number of states and in a
number of countries and almost
universally they have shown that many
more people have been infected and
recovered from the corona virus than
have active infections just yesterday
New York City of respond number of New
York State published a number for New
York City showing the 21% of people in
the city have been infected and
recovered they have antibodies and by
the way that number is probably low
because it takes a little while to
develop antibodies so over the course of
a couple weeks the number tends to rise
yeah there's no guarantee of that but
it's likely but in many other
jurisdictions there have been similar
findings you know in a school in France
a single high school in France 25
percent of students and teachers and and
parents were infected in sweden and
stockholm eleven percent in california
it looks more like three or four percent
in you know in geneva switzerland six
percent and again that does not mean
that there's not more you know virus out
there that's gonna you know there's not
gonna be more misery or you know some
people might be infected and ultimately
die because you have to get to a much
higher level than that to have what's
called herd immunity where the virus
basically has infected everybody it can
but those numbers suggest that the
infection fatality rate is well below
1% and and probably below 1/2 percent
and so and so that suggests again not
that this is not real and serious but
that it is less dangerous than we
thought but one of the bizarre things
that's happened is that the people the
same people who made these models many
of the same people you know based on
what now looks like faulty data and
questionable assumptions now that we're
getting really hard data from the
serology tests from these antibody tests
they're pushing back and saying oh well
the test those anybody test may not mean
anything there may be false positives or
or there may you know this means that so
many people have it and don't even know
it that it's more dangerous I mean so so
that first question about false positive
is a technical question but this idea
that there's antibody tests that um that
many people are infected and that's a
bad thing and have recovered is a bad
thing that's just nonsense there's that
that's a that's that's the opposite of
reality and why people won't acknowledge
that I don't know so so so yeah so let
me leave you with the testing and the
fact that by all accounts there's now
considerable evidence that the corona
virus has spread much more quickly or
and much more widely than we realized
and and that's a good thing the more of
us you know whether in the United States
or anywhere else who have gotten this
and recovered from it the better off we
are
so thank you very much I'm Alex Berenson
and I appreciate having had the chance
to talk to you
hello and welcome to the second half of
our program with Alex Berenson he just
given us an excellent talk on the
failure of expert predictions and models
my name is John Jay Miller I'm director
the Dow journalism program here at
Hillsdale College in Michigan and Alex
welcome back and thanks for agreeing to
take a few questions John it's a
pleasure I want to start with a big one
which is this you've given us this great
account of the problems of expertise and
what experts have been saying we're
seeing millions of people on the
unemployment rolls you mentioned the
problems hospitals are now facing have
experts led us into making a gigantic
public policy mistake well you know I I
don't think that's exactly the right way
to think about this you know the experts
provide data and predictions but it's
the job of political leaders you know
executive legislative and it's the job
of all of us to try to think about the
costs and benefits here and again there
there is a world in which the lockdowns
make sense though you know that's a
world in which a huge number of people
are dying from this and we really have
no choice but to you know have a
crippled Society for a long time until
we fix this that that is not the reality
of what we're seeing here even the worst
case projections don't fit that reality
and so it's up to all of us to you know
to show some critical judgment here and
not just hide out and I can tell you I
mean I don't know what your experience
has been but so again my wife is a
physician she does treat kovat patients
and we've made a conscious decision that
we're gonna try to keep our family you
know functioning as normally as we can
we're gonna go out with our kids we're
gonna take them you know to the grocery
store and stuff like that they're not
going to be terrified because I truly
believe that the mental health impact on
children here far far outweighs any
physical risk that they have but but
most people we know aren't doing that at
all most people are hunkered down
cowering in their homes I know I can
only imagine they're watching media
outlets that are putting the worst
possible spin on all this and they're
not looking they're not exercising any
critical judgment looking at any
scientific papers looking at any
government data for themselves and and I
know that you know against
a lot of this stuff is stuff that is
beyond you know the the an average
person's understanding certainly some of
the technical stuff around the you know
the biology of the virus but anybody can
can look at a projection and look at
what's actually happening that day and
judge for himself whether those two
numbers are the same and then ask what
it means if they're not the same and and
I just I feel like we've all let
ourselves down
what's a political leader supposed to do
it someone's listening to public health
officials listening to these studies
they're saying all kinds of different
things some of them are very scary and
frightening you don't want to make a
mistake you don't want to make a
decision it's gonna lead to lots of
deaths how is a political leader
supposed to judge between different
kinds of expert opinion and and land on
the right course well I think this is a
great question and here's the thing
the situation a month ago was different
than it is now things looked scarier a
month ago than they did now we have more
data and we know that outside of New
York City and possibly a couple other
hotspots there hasn't been a huge
overrun so so when more data comes in if
you care about data if you care about
science you should adjust your response
beyond that a political leader you know
you're not just the the president of a
nine year old in a nursing home you're
the president of a six year old in a
school who you know who may not have you
know who may have parents who are
abusive or neglectful and being seen by
a teacher that day is the only adult
who's gonna see that child who can make
sure that he or she is being taken care
of and not being abused you're the
president of a small business owner
who's invested his life in a you know in
getting his dry cleaning business
opening this week and all of a sudden it
can't exist anymore it can't work
anymore but he can't work as
non-essential we have to make trades and
and shutting the economy forever is not
a fair trade or a good trade and there
are things we could do that would
mitigate the harm to the most vulnerable
people here who again are overwhelmingly
elderly and you know and even within
that population the nursing home
population is especially vulnerable and
if we focused our attention on
protecting those people if we had more
temperature checks if we tried to make
sure that staff were being tested
regularly for the corona
if we if we said you know what if
there's any outbreak we're gonna make
sure that all these people get the best
care we can give them if we did that
preferentially maybe we'd be able to
actually reduce the number of deaths and
and at the same time have a functioning
society so we're the lockdown and
shutdown orders where they were they a
good idea based upon the information
that that leaders had at that time maybe
not the best information or the best
information available but maybe not good
information I mean I think that's a
that's a point that we can argue and
we'll argue about for years but to me
you know it's more important right now
April 24th what's the best thing to do
going forward what's the best thing to
do now that we have studies out of
Germany and other European countries
showing that social distancing without a
heart lockdown actually reduces the
infectivity of the virus in a way that
prevents these searches from happening
what's the best thing to do if there's
increasing questions about whether or
not the panic that a lockdown can cause
in the days before it's actually
happening you know but when it's
announced but before it happens might be
driving people to emergency rooms might
be causing them to trade the flu and
coronavirus and other illnesses and
actually gets them sicker and and you
know increases mortality as may have
happened in New York City last month I
think I think it doesn't really matter
you know it's it's for historians and
you know and I guess investigative
reporters ultimately to chase down how
the decisions that were made last month
were made I'm interested in making the
right decision right now so Alex what's
the right public policy solution right
now we're having this conversation on
Friday April 24th and today the governor
of Michigan just extended the stay at
home order in our state she loosened a
few restrictions there are a few new
ones but what would you recommend to the
governor of Michigan really any governor
if this person was to call you and say
Alex Berenson what should I do in my
state so there's a couple harder answers
to that and there's a couple easy ones
let me go with the harder ones first I
think in most states there there's not a
hospital system crisis which is almost
every state we can very quickly look at
reopening offices reopening retail and
then
you know in the next couple of weeks
maybe at hospitality you know at bars
and restaurants and then ultimately at
you know at at big events like like
concerts or sporting events there's very
very good data showing that most of the
transmission of this virus is intramural
or in hospitals and nursing homes or to
some extent on public transportation
that all the other methods of
transmission are secondary and so so
opening offices opening retail opening
construction letting people get back to
work makes sense there are risks in it
but that but it makes sense but here's
here's two things that are very low risk
that we should be doing right now right
as in today we should be letting people
go outside with no masks and you know if
they want to wear a mask that's fine but
outdoor transmission is not a major
vector or even a minor vector for this
virus there's very good data on this
from many countries now this is not how
it spreads and it's really bad for
people's mental health especially with
some are coming to deny them the chance
to be outside and it's really especially
bad for children and the second big
thing we should do right now is figure
out how to get schools reopened as
quickly as possible because children and
young adults are at very very low risk
for this again the data is the same all
over the world the number one risk
factor in you know in becoming sick or
dying from the coronaviruses age you
know they're a couple they've been a
couple of outlier cases where the media
has focused on you know young children
possibly dying in some of those cases
it's not even clear whether coronavirus
actually was a factor in the children's
death but remember many children die
every year from the flu you know
depending on the year could be 50 or 100
or 150 we don't shut society down for
that we don't shut schools down for that
it is unfair to children to deny them
the chance at schooling and in some
cases it's worse than that many children
in the United States 2,000 children in
the United States approximately a year
die from child abuse which is you know
far more than will ever die from Corona
and antis to lock these kids up in their
homes where teachers who might be the
only responsible adults in their lives
can't see them where they're stuck with
abusive or drug using parents all day
and and where their whole family's under
additional stress right now because that
you know parents might be jobless
they're worried about paying the rent is
just beyond wrong so we really should be
looking at focus at reopening schools
Alex we're running out of time I got one
more question for you and it draws from
your earlier book your book from last
year called tell your children which is
about marijuana and mental health and
violence and it was a subject of one of
the most read and debated issues of in
Primus which is the newsletter of
Hillsdale College ever ever published
you wrote that book last year and and
when when when we talk about coronavirus
of course we're talking about physical
health sometimes we don't always talk
about the mental health implications of
this disease and of the lockdown the
shutdown and so forth with these orders
with staying at home with people out of
work is there a greater threat now of
drug abuse whether it's whether it's
marijuana
or opioids or something else III think
there's some evidence of that at this
point you know we I don't know that we
have hard statistics on that and I'm
reluctant to go past you know what the
statistics say there's some evidence by
the way of an increase in domestic
violence already and again of child
abuse in terms of drug use it's it's
quite reasonable to assume that you know
both prescription pharmaceuticals like
benzodiazepines and you know and drugs
of abuse like like cannabis or you know
or alcohol or cocaine would be would be
things that people would turn to right
now to try to relieve their stress I'm
not sure we have that data yet there's
also considerable evidence that economic
deprivation drives up drug use drives up
suicides
you know the opioid crisis is sometimes
called the crisis a death of deaths of
despair and it would be surprising if
something similar didn't happen because
of this you know perhaps because my wife
is a psychiatrist so she's at you know
she's a doctor a medical doctor but
she's also focused on mental health I'm
pretty I'm pretty attuned to this issue
and it's something we really should be
talking about much more
Alex Berenson thanks so much for talking
to us about expert opinion and models
and their failures
thanks very much Sean and thanks to all
of you for watching this program from
Hillsdale College